sólo a 2 de enero ya fue uno de los
autos más esperados del año el de los
restos de Pelé la leyenda brasileña del
fútbol que pasará 24 horas en el estadio
de fútbol de Santos para que sus
seguidores le puedan dar el último adiós
es un sentimiento de pérdida de un ídolo
para todos es un ídolo además de una
persona que elevó el nombre de Brasil en
todos los rincones
pero Jehová con una misión cumplida es
un ídolo nacional y mundial
las primeras horas del velatorio del
Astro además de miles de fans acudieron
figuras importantes desde varios
miembros de la Corte Suprema del país
que también quisieron despedirse hasta
el presidente de la FIFA ya ni infantino
que acompañó a los familiares de la
Estrella en el Duelo y pidió que todos
los países le rindieran un pequeño
homenaje vamos a
a pedir a todas las federaciones en el
mundo entero 211 países
que nombran un estadio en cada país del
mundo con el nombre con el nombre de
pelé porque creo que los jóvenes en el
mundo entero las futuras generaciones
tienen que saber
Y recordarse de quién era Pelé el
conocido como rey del fútbol que murió a
los 82 años a causa de un cáncer será
enterrado el martes en una ceremonia más
íntima pelea marcó la vida de miles de
Amantes del fútbol en Brasil y en todo
el mundo y siempre será recordado por su
yogo bonito